[Music]
my name is Ahamed Weinberg this year
like many before it I'm fasting for
Ramadan that means I wake up before the
Sun rises and eat everything in my
fridge and then I can't eat again until
the Sun sets I do this for an entire
month you're probably wondering why is
your last name Jewish why why are you
white what has happening let me explain
my mother was one of ten children in an
Irish Catholic family
one day she joined a Native American
tribe and they called her hat woman
better than sunblock I guess this is her
at the end of her spiritual journey as a
Sufi Muslim
she was never sunburned again in 1988
she married a Jewish man from Brooklyn
who had also found this long look at
that nose the answering machine in my
house growing up was assalamualaikum
you've reached the Weinberg's please
leave a message
nobody left a message I go crazy every
day I can't drink or eat I usually want
to have sex with my fridge around 4:00
[Music]
she's old and her skin is yellow she
doesn't stop humming but something about
her I love it's what's inside that
counts
[Music]
you